[Music]
plenty of Mama's our representative
oceans a Sandra Kate and Mindy all moms
mom power yes although in this movie
Nance they are a group of con artists
because they are but have they ever
taken something that didn't belong to
them in real life well it was the
million dollar question only a good girl
gone bad
good at okay so you guys have so many
fans we went to the fans to ask what
they wanted to ask you if they had any
questions and we picked our favorite oh
I want to know who has actually stolen
something in their life on the spot
that's you it's Ariana yeah that is
Rihanna I would say yes oh I was young I
was young and I didn't know any better I
did I did I did for was a candy bar yes
always a candy family was in the candy
family did you sold stolen nothing
stones amassed all these shoes far away
souls with the porch thank you that's a
really important stuff I have okay spill
it there was the high school thievery
that was happening and then there was
like the childhood thieving that was
happening that's a high school Oh see I
was thinking I would do the other get
sued by the clothing company that I used
to steal from on Columbus Avenue it was
a body in velvet bodysuit have snap crop
but I was like that was a couple of my
friends and I did it together butyou
know did you are my girl a Belva body or
does the one in and share that we all
stole about that bodysuit oh my god so
the days of sticky fingers may be long
gone but each of these ladies like their
oceans eight characters are at the top
of their fashion game so if you could
steal from another celebrity's closet
who would that be
okay fair sharona's closet when Stefani
Yancy's Coachella looks very good I
would steal those looks weren't as cool
I would like um Karl Lagerfeld's closet
oh yeah oh I would have to dip into
Kate's a little bit I would steal
everything she had on that can
she's the dresser she's brilliant never
made a woman
my underwear oh my god don't tell me
Caitlyn chat had on granny panties under
that just wanna remind you it's being
filmed I want this to be nonstop there
yeah
[Music]